Il est toujours salé Monté ?
Ce matin il faisait la gueule en tout cas…
mais du coup je pige pas, il s’est passé un truc entre vous ?
C’était la saison d’avant.
Avec Valentine, on l’a un peu laissé tout seul. Mais c’était pour des bonnes raisons.
Je lui aurai bien demandé de m’expliquer l’expression “être salé”. Vu qu’il l’est en plus, il l’aurait bien illustré mais il ne voudra jamais.
Hier, il m’a presque forcé à participer à sa collab bizarre.
Franchement, c’était perturbant.
Mes agneaux, l’heure est grave.
D’ici la fin du siècle, le niveau de la mer sera monté d’un à trois mètres.
280 millions de réfugiés climatiques seront chassés de leur demeure côtière.
Des villes entières seront rayées de la carte.
Adieu Bangkok, New-York, Miami, Rio et Palavas-les-Flots.
Heureusement pour vous, j’ai LA solution à ce problème.
Je suis hyperdocteure internationale en biotechnologie neuroquantique à boucles, et voici mon verdict :
il faut nous rendre résistants au sel.
Comme ça, on pourra vivre les pieds dans l’eau une rotule en l’air, comme les flamants, c’est chic.
Ou mieux : on construira des villes sous-marines,
une Atlantide 2.0 !
Et pour ce faire, on va s’inspirer du vivant,
qui est un incubateur d’innovations depuis 3 milliards et demi d’années.
Ensemble, construisons un monde halotolérant. Allez, en selle !
Merci d'avoir acheté ma formation pour faire de vous un être résistant au sel.
Vous avez raison de me faire confiance.
Le vrai problème, outre le capitalisme,
c’est que le sel est un cadeau empoisonné.
Un poison nécessaire à la vie.
Un poison parce que si vous en mangez 25 grammes d’un coup, donc 4 cuillères à soupe, vous mourrez. De déshydratation.
Le sel est aussi un facteur de risque d’hypertension artérielle, de maladies cardio-vasculaires et de cancer de l’estomac.
Et il peut aussi favoriser l’ostéoporose.
Mais attention, pas le sel en soi : l’excès de capitalisme.
C’est si on dépasse 5 g/jour.
Ce qu’on fait allègrement tout le temps.
D’après l’Organisation mondiale de la santé, la plupart des gens consomment
9 à 12 grammes de sel par jour en moyenne, donc le double de l’apport maximum recommandé.
L’Elise Lucet qui sommeille en nous a envie de tout de suite jeter l’opprobre sur les plats industriels parce que les vilains lobbies cachent
des puces 5G dans les rillettes de poulet pour nous forcer à nous vacciner.
Alors oui, les plats préparés sont trop salés. Mais figurez-vous qu’en France,
la plus grande partie du sel qu’on consomme provient d’abord…
du pain et des biscottes, puis de la charcuterie, des sauces, et seulement après des plats cuisinés, des fromages et des soupes.
En résumé, rien de tel qu’un bon petit sandwich jambon-emmental accompagné d'un potage aux lasagnes surgelées.
Mais je m’égare.
Pour paraphraser ce bon vieux médecin suisse Paracelse, point trop n’en faut.
Mais point pas assez n'en faut non plus.
Car le sel est nécessaire à la vie.
Sans lui, on mourrait de déshydratation.
Les éléments chimiques qu’il contient, le chlore et le sodium, nous sont indispensables.
Ils servent notamment à la contraction de nos muscles, à la transmission des influx nerveux
et au bon fonctionnement de notre système immunitaire.
Bref, comme disait Frédéric François,
je ne peux pas vivre sans sel.
Et vu qu’on l’élimine en partie par la transpiration et aux cabinets, il faut bien qu’on compense ces pertes en en consommant, du sel.
Car il est essen…sel. tiel.
En tout cas, vous avez saisi le côté ambivalent de la chose.
Eh ben sachez qu’on n’est pas les seuls à grimacer quand y a trop de sel.
Très peu d’espèces aiment ça. Mais certaines s’en sont fait une spécialité, comme la Provence et les pieds paquets ou l’Auvergne et les tripoux.
Prenez Dunaliella salina,
l’algue rosée des étangs qui contribue à donner aux flamants leur couleur chatoyante.
Cette algue supporte plus de 300 grammes de sel par litre d’eau !
C’est énorme.
Sachant que l’eau de mer est à 35 g/L et que c’est déjà violent pour les bestioles qui y vivent.
Cette algue est d’ailleurs la plante principale, sinon la seule, qui squatte les environnements extrêmes comme la mer Morte ou les marais salants,
là où on fait évaporer l'eau pour cueillir le sel.
Ça veut dire que dans ces endroits, toute la chaîne alimentaire dépend de cette petite cellule rose.
Mais à part quelques warriors comme elle, l’immense majorité des espèces tire la tronche quand c’est trop salé.
C’est aussi pour ça qu’on sale les aliments pour les conserver. Ca permet de tuer les microbes qui voudraient en faire leur quatre heures.
Ho salut Ben ! Qu’est ce que tu fais là ?
Salut ! Y a Monté qui m’a dit de passer, du coup, je suis passé.
Et tu ne veux pas participer à ma vidéo sur le sel ? Ça me fera des abonnés.
Vu le contexte actuel avec Monté, je n’ai pas trop envie de me mettre mal avec lui.
Non mais ça va, il s’en remettra.
Je sais pas. Là, je viens de faire le trajet en bagnole. C’était long.
- Ca te changera les idées.
- Mais moi, je n’y connais pas grand chose à ton sujet là.
Mais t’improviseras, de toute façon, c’est comme ça qu’on fait en science.
Je sais pas, y a le temps de setup, avec le micro et tout là...
Je m’en occupe ça, on fait un truc à l’arrache. Ce sera très bien, c’est pour Youtube.
En tout cas, le sel, c’est vrai que ça fait hyper longtemps qu’on le consomme. On a déjà des traces depuis le Néolithique.
On va dire depuis 8000 avant notre ère,
on a des traces d’exploitation de sel déjà.
Même si on a déjà beaucoup de mines qui se sont développées au 2e millénaire avant notre ère.
En fait, le sel, ça sert vraiment à la conservation des aliments d’une part.
Mais ça sert aussi à d’autres choses,
comme par exemple la tannerie, le travail du cuir, la conservation des peaux.
Le sel, au début, c’est un petit peu rare
donc ça vaut cher parce qu’en plus, c’est demandé. Il y a une vraie utilité.
Assez rapidement, le sel va servir de monnaie d’échange.
On va échanger du sel contre autre chose. Le mot salaire vient en partie de sel.
Parce que les soldats romains notamment étaient en partie payés avec du sel.
Du coup, le sel est relativement lié à l’économie et ça pas que durant l’Antiquité,
puisque durant la période Médiéval aussi.
Philippe VI, en 1332, il va mettre en place
un truc qu’on est nombreux à connaître même si on a des souvenirs un petit peu vague de l’école,
c’est la gabelle.
À l’époque, le commerce du sel représente quand même une manne financière hyper importante
pour le royaume, et lui, il n’a pas envie de laisser échapper tout ce flouze
en dehors du royaume, donc il met en place la gabelle qui est une taxe sur le sel.
Et concrètement, comment ça va se mettre en place ? Il fait monter des greniers un petit peu partout sur tout le territoire.
Des greniers qui vont servir à stocker le sel, et les gens vont devoir aller se servir dans ces stocks là et donc payer une taxe
sur ce sel qu’il va récupérer, avec des prix qui sont bien évidemment contrôlés par la couronne et que la couronne va récupérer.
Cette taxe, tout le monde la paye, sauf
des grands privilégiés ou des gens qui ont des caractères comme les Bretons par exemple.
Parce que quand le Royaume de Bretagne va se rattacher au Royaume de France en 1532
ils vont négocier tout un tas de trucs les Bretons, ils disent on veut bien mais d’accord,
on veut quand même des trucs.
Et y a notamment le fait d’être exempté de la gabelle.
Et ça va produire des trucs un peu rigolo parce que
comme on le disait dans l’histoire de l’alimentation, le sel sert à la conservation. Et notamment la conservation du beurre.
Et ce qu’il va se passer, c’est que dans tout le Royaume, on va essayer de ne plus mettre de sel dans le beurre pour éviter que le beurre soit trop cher parce qu’il est taxé.
Et donc on va trouver d’autres alternatives.
Alors qu’en Bretagne, on est free, on n’a pas à payer les taxes sur le sel.
Donc, vive le beurre salé ! On continue à en mettre dedans. Et c’est de là que vient le beurre salé.
Bretagne ! 500 ans sur le sel !
Revenons à notre plan pour un monde d’après halotolérant.
Pour savoir comment résister au sel, il faut d’abord comprendre quel est son problème.
Et la réponse est dans la question.
Non, pas du tout. La réponse est l’osmose.
Vous vous êtes sûrement demandé pourquoi le sel donnait soif.
Oui, on s’attaque aux vraies questions ici. C’est du journalisme poil à gratter.
Dans cette vidéo au vitriol, la lanceuse d’alerte que je suis vous apprend donc que le sel attire l’eau.
L'eau va toujours du milieu le moins salé au plus salé.
Ou plutôt, du milieu le plus dilué vers le plus concentré en solutés.
Les solutés c’est en gros tous les gaz, liquides et solides dissous dans notre eau.
Et ce phénomène qu’on observe est physique, c’est ce qu’on appelle l’osmose.
Pour le dire autrement, les dieux de la chimie vont vouloir égaliser les concentrations dans les deux milieux et donc il y aura plus d'eau là où il y a plus de sel.
Ou plus généralement, d'ions.
Saline D’ions.
En fait, l’eau dit aux solutés “j’irai où tu iras”.
Si vous mangez une tartine de morue aux anchois accompagnée d’un espuma d’algues sur son lit de frites,
les 10 kg de sel qui sont maintenant en solution dans votre sang vont aspirer l’eau hors de vos cellules.
Ces cellules vont se retrouver toutes flétries et vont vous supplier de vous enfiler un litre de flotte pour compenser.
Et de ne plus jamais,
jamais,
saler votre plat avant de le goûter.
Donc, pour résumer, le sel en excès a la fâcheuse tendance de nous déshydrater.
Et c’est pareil pour tout le monde.
Si vous salez votre pot de fleurs, le sel va retenir l’eau du sol et c’est comme si vous aviez téléporté votre pétunia dans le désert.
Plongez votre poisson rouge dans la mer, Bubulle va se vider de son eau.
Attends, tu lui fais quoi ?
Mais non, c’est une expérience de pensée ! On ne va pas vraiment le faire.
Si on le faisait, notre poisson d’eau douce
dans l’eau salée finirait tout sec comme une chips alors qu’il baigne littéralement dans l’eau. C’est un peu ironique.
Ouais alors t’en gentille Valentine, ne le prend pas mal, mais je serai hyper rassuré si tu te tenais éloignée du bassin qui est au fond du jardin.
T’as peur que je tombe dedans ?
Heureusement, certaines bestioles et plantes ont développé des innovations brevetées salt-proof.
Et c’est justement d’elles qu’on va pouvoir s’inspirer pour bâtir notre humain 2.0 du turfu.
Les poissons marins, par exemple, ont un merveilleux mécanisme d’osmorégulation (qui, comme son nom l’indique, permet de réguler l’osmose).
Comme ils sont moins salés que leur environnement, ils ont tendance à perdre de l’eau,
comme notre Bubulle, et à se faire envahir par le sel.
Du coup, ils boivent leur race pour contrer cette perte d’eau.
Donc pour répondre à cette autre question que vous ne vous êtes sûrement jamais posée, oui, les poissons boivent.
Enfin, les poissons marins.
Ils boivent beaucoup, même.
Mais le hic, c’est que cette eau est salée, eh oui c’est ballot.
Du coup, ils la filtrent grâce à leur système rénal et leurs branchies,
lesquelles leur permettent de relarguer le sel.
Habile ! Et en plus, ils urinent très peu, pour ne pas gaspiller cette précieuse ressource.
Donc quand vous dites que vous pouvez bien faire pipi dans la mer parce que les poissons, eux, ne se gênent pas,
sachez qu’ils vous regardent avec mépris
et constipation. Consternation.
Du coup, puisque tu es là et que tu m’emmènes dans ce joli cadre bucolique.
Tu peux m’expliquer comment ça marche les espèces migratrices, genre les saumons.
Comment ils passent d’un milieu marin à un milieu d’eau douce sans mourir.
Du coup, les saumons naissent en rivière.
Voilà.
Ah cool. Abonnez-vous !
Donc les saumons naissent en rivière, donc en eau douce,
où ils vont rester un à deux ans.
Ces petits saumons, on les appelle des tacons.
Et au bout de ces un à deux ans,
ils subissent une métamorphose qui s’appelle la smoltification. Donc, ils deviennent des petits smolts.
Qui choisit ce nom ?
Il y a plusieurs types de changements
que l’on peut observer chez ces petits poissons.
Des changements au niveau physique, leurs yeux vont grossir pour s’adapter à l’obscurité.
Leur corps va s’allonger.
Leur peau va s’argenter.
Tu as aussi des changements au niveau des comportements.
Donc ils ne sont plus sédentaires et ils vont devenir grégaires. Donc se regrouper en banc.
Et puis tu as des changements physiologiques, où les mécanismes osmo-régulateurs vont s’inverser
pour s’adapter à la salinité.
Une fois en mer, les saumons vont se diriger vers le Nord de l’océan Atlantique pour manger, grossir toussa toussa,
où ils vont rester à peu près un à trois ans.
Puis les saumons adultes vont revenir en rivière pour se reproduire.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la migration de montaison.
Et du coup, le saumon passe au cours de sa vie de l’eau douce, à l’eau salée,
- re à l’eau douce parfois même re au salée.
- Et re à l'eau douce, et re...
- Non.
Du coup tu as expliqué comment se passe l’osmose en mer.
En rivière, c’est l’inverse. Le saumon est plus salé que son environnement.
L’eau entre par osmose.
Et le sel s’en échappe par diffusion.
Donc, pour garder son équilibre interne, ils vont arrêter de boire.
Il va uriner beaucoup pour évacuer son excès d’eau.
Et il va capter les sels et les minéraux dont il a besoin via des cellules dans ses branchies.
- Donc, il fait exactement l’inverse.
- Exactement.
Tu as une méthode d’ailleurs pour étudier la migration des poissons qui s’appelle l’otolithométrie.
Un nom un petit peu barbare, parce qu’en fait, chez la plupart des poissons, tu as dans leur oreille quelque chose qui s’appelle des otolithes.
Oto = oreille et lithos, pierre.
Et c’est des compressions calcaires qui vont enregistrer la trace chimique des eaux
tout au long de la vie du poisson.
Donc une espèce de boîte noire naturelle, et du coup, les changements de salinité s’enregistrent
sur ces otolithes et quand tu l’étudies,
tu peux voir si le poisson est passé d’eau salée à eau douce tout au long de sa vie.
Mais par contre, pour voir ça, il faut tuer le poisson.
- Et du coup les otolithes, y en a chez les humains aussi ?
- Aussi !
Trop cool !
Ça veut dire que si on arrive à être résistant au sel.
- On pourrait passer de rivière à mer et tout et ce serait enregistré dans nos oreilles.
- Oui !
- C'est trop cool.
- Oui.
- On fait ça ?
- Aller.
- On monte une startup.
- Aller, c'est parti.
Donc pour survivre dans un milieu salé, il faudra déjà pouvoir compter sur vos reins.
Vous pouvez boire abondamment et recracher le sel, par exemple par vos branchies, comme le font les poissons.
Mais pour vous aider à mieux éliminer ce poison, vous pouvez vous faire pousser des glandes à sel dans le rectum,
comme les raies et les requins.
C’est la grande tendance automne-hiver.
Ces glandes filtrent l’eau de mer que le poisson avale et elles stockent le sel.
Moi je connais une tortue qui respire par le cul.
On trouve aussi des glandes à sel chez plein d’autres animaux marins.
Et ça, c’est une bonne nouvelle : vous pouvez choisir l’orifice par lequel vous allez recracher tout ce sel !
Par les narines, comme certains iguanes qui éternuent du sel. Ou comme les oiseaux.
Leurs glandes sont situées entre les yeux et ils excrètent par les narines qui sont sur leur bec une solution très salée.
Du sérum physiologique en guise de morve, quoi.
Et ensuite, ils évacuent tout ça en secouant la tête.
On a tous vu ce geste caractéristique des mouettes sur la plage ou alors des albatros qui suivent,
indolents compagnons de voyage, le navire glissant sur les gouffres amers.
A chaque fois je le remarque depuis la poupe de mon yacht et je me dis qu’on n’apprécie pas assez les plaisirs simples de ma vie. De la vie.
Autre option, vous pouvez pleurer du sel, comme les tortues de mer qui ont des glandes lacrymales modifiées. Ou comme les masculinistes sur Twitter.
Sinon, vous pouvez avoir des glandes à sel sur la langue, comme le crocodile de mer, ou sous la langue comme les serpents de mer.
C’est en fait des glandes salivaires modifiées.
Finalement, ces glandes à sel, y’en a chez un bon paquet de reptiliens.
A votre avis, pourquoi Emmanuel Macron sale toujours ses plats ? Et s’il avait, lui aussi, les glandes ?
Donc, on trouve pas mal d’espèces qui arborent fièrement des glandes à sel parmi les reptiles et les oiseaux,
et même chez leurs lointains tontons et tatas, les dinosaures et les mosasaures.
Normalement, filtrer l’eau de mer, ça aurait dû être le job de leurs reins.
Mais il s’avère que les reins des reptiles et des oiseaux sont vraiment pas très performants comparé à ceux des mammifères.
Du coup, la nature a dû trouver des pirouettes pour s’en sortir.
Qui, en modifiant ses glandes lacrymales, qui en modifiant ses glandes salivaires, qui en martelant le 49.3.
Et ça, c’est un bon exemple de ce qu’on appelle la convergence évolutive.
Ces glandes seraient apparues indépendamment chez plein d’espèces
et elles leur auraient permis de coloniser les milieux salés.
Comme ils présentaient un avantage évolutif,
ces organes auraient été conservés par la sélection naturelle et transmis de génération en génération.
Comme un précieux héritage qui vous permet de moucher du sel.
Mais c’est pas tout ! On trouve aussi des glandes à sel chez les végétaux.
C’est pas du tout les mêmes structures, mais la fonction est la même.
Si vous préférez transpirer du sel par les pores de vos feuilles, allez voir par exemple du côté de certaines poacées, qu’on appelait graminées avant, comme Distichlis spicata.
Et si les glandes c’est pas trop votre truc, faites comme certaines plantes.
Vous pouvez décider de stocker le sel dans des poches, qu’on appelle des vacuoles, ou carrément dans certains organes.
Prenez le groupe des salicornes. Une plante typique de la sansouïre.
C’est comme ça qu’on appelle les prés salés en Camargue et ce mot m'emplit de joie.
Sansouïre.
Les salicornes sont des plantes halophytes.
C’est-à-dire qu’elles supportent des concentrations plus ou moins élevées de sel mais elles font aussi très bien sans.
Pour faire une analogie, les halophytes seraient les personnes qui vont sur Twitter principalement pour s’informer
et qui slaloment comme elles peuvent entre les dramas.
Et puis il y a aussi celles qui vont sur Twitter rien que pour les dramas.
Celles-là, ce sont les halophytes obligatoires ou halophiles.
Ces plantes-là dépendent carrément du sel pour vivre.
Et c’est le cas de certaines espèces de salicornes, justement.
Et la licorne de la sansouïre a une technique bien à elle.
Elle absorbe de l’eau salée par les racines,
vu qu’elle a un peu les pieds dedans,
et elle conduit le sel dans des vieilles feuilles qui ne lui servent plus et dont elle se débarrasse ensuite.
Mais n’oubliez pas de stocker le sel dans des poches dédiées et surtout pas en vrac,
en tout cas si vous êtes une plante, sinon ça va vous cramer de l’intérieur.
Eh oui, le sel est toxique pour les végétaux.
Mais ça a aussi ses avantages de le conserver dans ses tissus.
Ca nous permet de garder de l’eau avec !
On ressemble un peu à un bonhomme Michelin après, mais c’est utile en cas de disette.
En tout cas, c’est la stratégie des plantes grasses, qui sont un peu des gourdes ambulantes.
Comme moi.
Et le fait de posséder des organes charnus gorgés d’eau comme ça, c’est ce qu’on appelle la crassulescence.
Et figurez-vous que la salicorne est crassulescente, je trouve que ces mots traduisent très bien la fraîcheur et le doux fumet des étangs.
Bon. C’est bien mignon, ces histoires de glandes, d’amputation et de bonhomme Michelin, mais il nous reste toujours le plus gros problème à régler :
cette histoire d’osmose.
On a vu au début que l’eau allait toujours du milieu le plus dilué vers le plus concentré.
Si vous êtes moins salé que votre environnement, vous allez mécaniquement vous vider de votre eau.
Donc il faut trouver une astuce
pour rendre votre milieu intérieur autant voire plus concentré que le milieu extérieur
pour que l’eau vienne et ne reparte pas.
Et là encore, la nature a des idées.
Pour rétablir cet équilibre osmotique, vous pouvez vous mettre à produire des petites molécules sympa, comme des sucres, pour jouer les figurants dans le décor.
Elles sont là pour augmenter la concentration en solutés dans votre “sang”,
mais aussi pour neutraliser les radicaux libres liés au stress d'un excès de sel.
C’est ce que font certains microbes comme la levure de boulanger, par exemple, ou cette fameuse algue rosée comme le vin dont on a parlé au début.
Elles produisent du glycérol.
Le glycérol, ça a un nom barbare mais en fait c'est un truc ultra courant.
C'est un liquide transparent et visqueux au goût sucré qu'on utilise dans plein de choses, des biscuits industriels au liquide des cigarettes électroniques jusqu’aux suppositoires, à la nitroglycérine et à l’anti-gel.
Sinon, plutôt que de devenir une usine à suppos, vous pouvez juste oublier de sortir les poubelles. C’est-à-dire conserver vos déchets métaboliques dans votre sang, au lieu de les évacuer.
En plus, le zéro déchet, c’est à la mode.
C’est ce que font les requins et les raies (encore eux).
Leurs reins filtrent l’urée, comme nos reins à nous.
Et plutôt que d’envoyer cette urée vers la sortie,
ils la réinjectent dans le système.
Donc en gros, leur sang et leurs tissus vont être imbibés de leur propre urine.
Ca leur permet, tout comme le glycérol des levures, d’éviter que l’eau qu’ils contiennent ne s’enfuie en mer comme mon papa marin-pêcheur quand j’avais 9 ans.
Je ne l’ai jamais revu depuis.
Et c’est pour ça que si on cuisine du requin ou de la raie, il faut d’abord les laisser tremper dans du lait pendant plusieurs heures
pour les débarrasser de ce petit goût d’ammoniac.
Sinon ce sera ni croquant, ni fondant.
Ça sera juste dégueu.
Plusieurs heures, par contre, ça va pas suffire pour laver votre honneur, parce que c’est le groupe d’animaux qui présente le plus haut risque d’extinction parmi tous les vertébrés.
Et n’oubliez pas de saler avant de servir !
En résumé, pour coloniser les milieux marins à la façon de ceux qui y vivent déjà, vous pouvez :
boire beaucoup et recracher du sel par l’orifice de votre choix grâce à des glandes à sel (en option),
ou bien le stocker dans des poches dédiées.
Mais attention en montant sur la balance, il y aura une petite rétention d’eau à prévoir.
Vous pouvez aussi stocker le sel dans un organe dont vous n’avez plus l’usage et vous amputer par la suite.
Et n’oubliez pas de sécréter des petites molécules sympas dans votre sang pour rétablir l’équilibre osmotique et ne pas risquer de finir tout desséchés !
Bon, pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous, malgré toute la foi que j’ai en l’humain augmenté,
je ne pense pas qu’on puisse vraiment devenir salt-proof un jour.
Tout cela était une vaste ruse de ma part pour vous montrer
l’éventail d’adaptations que la nature avait développé pour
conquérir un milieu somme toute relativement pas très accueillant.
Éventail non exhaustif, évidemment. Je vous ai pas parlé des papilles anales des larves de moustique par exemple.
Mais déjà, ça permet de voir se dessiner de belles convergences évolutives,
puisqu’on retrouve les mêmes adaptations apparues indépendamment chez plein d’organismes, comme le glycérol chez les levures et les algues.
Mais soyez pas jaloux pour autant. Avec ou sans glande à sel dans le rectum, vous êtes fantastiques.
Car vous aussi, en ce moment-même, vous osmorégulez.
Remerciez vos reins, qui régulent en continu la quantité de sodium dans votre sang pour qu’il y en ait juste ce qu’il faut.
Bon, pas au point où on pourrait vivre dans un marais salant, tel un Shrek du littoral, mais au point où on ne meurt pas après avoir englouti
3 soupières de moules-frites à volonté, et c’est déjà bien.
Mais si je vous parle de tout ça, c’est pas seulement pour vous refourguer mon programme et vous donner l’opportunité de financer mes prochaines vacances à Courchevel.
Non, c’est parce qu’effectivement, changement climatique oblige, notre avenir sera bel et bien salé.
On n’en entend pas plus parler que ça, et pourtant c’est un enjeu crucial des décennies à venir.
Nos sols se salent.
La mer monte et infiltre les nappes phréatiques de plus en plus loin à l’intérieur des terres.
Mais pas que, c’est aussi à cause d’une irrigation mal faite.
Par exemple si vous arrosez trop d’un coup, l’eau peut s’évaporer et précipiter les sels minéraux qu’elle contient, surtout sous un climat aride.
Sans même parler du salage des routes en hiver.
Vous savez, ce truc que les municipalités font deux mois après le début des chutes de neige parce qu’elles ont été
complètement prises au dépourvu par cette météo si imprévisible chaque année à la même date.
Du coup, ça sale les sols.
Et pour la biodiversité et l’agriculture, c’est pas glop.
Parce qu’un sol salé devient peu à peu stérile et qu’on peut pas vraiment revenir en arrière après.
Ce qui signifie qu’on perd des terres cultivables.
20% des terres irriguées sur la planète seraient déjà touchées par ce phénomène de salinisation,
soit plus de 800 millions d’hectares.
Et ça augmente chaque année.
On peut imaginer utiliser des plantes halophytes pour accumuler le sel et dessaler les sols.
C’est ce qu’on appelle de la phytoremédiation.
Ou bien, on trouve des plantes cultivées qui arrivent à pousser sur ces terrains-là.
Voilà pourquoi les chercheurs et les agronomes scrutent les plantes et les animaux de ces milieux-là.
Si on arrivait à percer tous leurs secrets, on pourrait essayer de sélectionner des espèces résistantes au sel.
On a même commencé à identifier des gènes de tolérance à la salinité.
Et c’est pas tout.
En agriculture, y’a pas que la plante qui importe, mais aussi la terre autour.
Et je trouve ça assez incroyable.
On s’est rendus compte que certaines bactéries et champignons du sol pouvaient aider les plantes à mieux tolérer le sel,
notamment parce que ces microbes régulent l’expression des gènes de la plante
pour lui faire économiser de l’eau et pour qu’elle produise des hormones de croissance.
Comme des chefs d'orchestre discrets qui se planquent au pied des végétaux.
C’est un peu fou quand même.
Tout ça pour dire qu’il y a encore plein de choses à découvrir et je trouve ça hyper enthousiasmant.
Bref, l’Atlantide 2.0 c’est pas pour demain, mais si on fait gaffe à irriguer correctement nos champs,
on ne sera pas tous obligés de manger des équidés crasseux - de la salicorne en 2100.
Bon, c'est une conclusion relativement salée mais pour nous quitter sur une touche d'hilarité,
voici le mot de la fin :
sansouïre.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo. Si vous l’avez aimé, n’hésitez pas à la liker,
à la partager sur les réseaux sociaux, abonnez-vous la cloche, et si vous voulez parler des reptiliens qui sont au gouvernement,
n’hésitez pas à nous rejoindre sur le Discord du Vortex.
Et je suis présentement en direct sur ma chaine Touiche ScienceDeComptoir dont le lien sera en description.
N’hésitez pas à me rejoindre si vous regardez cette vidéo alors qu’elle vient d’être diffusée parce que j’y serai et on pourra débriefer tout ça ensemble.
Venez, ça va être chouette.
Ecoutez, je connais pas vos histoires et je sais pas pourquoi ces vacances commencent avec une espèce de rivalité comme ça.
Par contre, moi ce que je sais faire,
c’est proposer des plans en deux étapes.
Tiou stepse.
Vas-y, on t’écoute.
Alors, la première étape, c’est de trouver le coupable idéal.
Et après, on va venir lui charger sa barque.
Par contre, il ne faut pas que ce soit quelqu’un qui puisse revenir pendant le séjour et nous embêter, tu vois ?
Il s’appelle un Créatif, c’était notre 4e colloc dans la saison précédente.
Et en plus, il est responsable.
Et bah parfait, tout le sel que vous avez toutes les deux là.
On va le prendre, on le met sur la barque.
Et puis, on le transmet à la deuxième étape.
Qui est ?
Un barbecue, avec, plein de gens.
D'ailleurs Marie, j'ai préparé une liste.
Mais je ne les connais pas ces gens moi.
Tu vas les connaître.
Parce qu’il n’y a rien de plus fort qu’un réseau social entièrement basé
sur la cuisson de saucisses.